welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and in cursions incoming to the MCU
with an interesting tidbit from the
Marvels and some possible updates about
Avengers Secret Wars and Doctor Strange
3. also is viral Studios swapping out
Kang for Doom I'm gonna break down a
bunch of interesting and possibly
connected things we just learned this
week about some upcoming MCU incursion
events what they're going to look like
and a general reminder of where Dr
Strange in the Multiverse of Menace
actually left things how that movie
actually might make sense at the end of
the day please subscribe to all three
channels in the new rockstars Network
also reminders sagastra has informed us
that entertainment journalists like new
rockstars are allowed to continue
covering movies like this but you know
what we joined these unions and call
into the studios and streamers to make a
fair deal with the screenwriters and the
professional working actors okay in a
spread with total film earlier this week
the Marvels director Nia DeCosta talked
about what it was like working with Iman
villani whom we know from our interview
with her last year is a true Marvel nerd
with her own notebook filled with MCU
lore questions and factoids so much so
that she's not afraid to pick fights
with Kevin feige over 616 versus one
nine nine nine nine nine nine DeCosta
said that she and villani had several
conversations about the MCU at large
during production on the Marvels and
that they were both quote bristling over
how the MCU is handling incursions and
that DeCosta finds the explanation in
Doctor Strange's Multiverse of Madness
quote always very stressful now why
would Dacosta and villani need to even
talk about incursions unless they
factored into the plot of the Marvels in
some way we know the Bengals have the
power to open Rifts in space-time a
process that may erode the fabric of
reality a little too much over repeated
usage and results in a barrier between
reality's weakening and making this
universe more prone to an incursion a
deserter a druid a mutant and a tucken
cyborg dog are tasked with vanquishing
an ancient demon where they'll have to
evade Monsters Warlords cannibals in one
angry ex-girlfriend along the way that's
the premise of a cool new graphic novel
called the Codex that we are so excited
to partner with on their Kickstarter
campaign the 196 page Dark Fantasy Epic
from hayburner Studios is the first of
six planned volumes from writer Corey
crater and a team of talented artists
we've read an advanced copy of the first
volume and we love the mix of sci-fi and
Fantasies all set in a fully realized
post-apocalyptic world it's like if
George RR Martin wrote an X-Men comic
setting in the world of Mad Max it's got
some great dialogue beautiful art and a
great lived-in relationship between its
main characters all the pages already
completed and all the artists have been
paid so the kickstarter campaign is
really a way for you the interested
graphic novel readers in the new rock
stars audience to discover the work so
click the link in this video's
description to check out the kickstarter
and support the project and as a
reminder in Multiverse of Madness Reed
Richards of universe 838 played by John
Krasinski said it's even your arrival
here confuses and destabilizes reality
the larger the footprint you leave
behind the greater the risk of an
incursion an incursion occurs when the
boundary between two universes erodes
and they Collide destroying one or both
entirely but I doubt it was Richard's
word choice his explanation that villani
and DeCosta take issue with because
let's face it it was more or less
paraphrased exactly from Reed's
explanation of incursions from Jonathan
Hickman's New Avengers vol 1 everything
dies issue which is really the first
step on the road Through Time runs out
and the 2015 Secret Wars crossover event
really I think what they're referring to
was that rather than molecule man being
the Anchor Point for all these
incursions in the comics in the films at
least according to Multiverse of Madness
it's gonna be doctor strange for villani
and DeCosta to bristle against the
definition of an incursions being
different from the comics they must know
something Beyond those seeds being
planted the Multiverse Madness and as
storytellers on the cosmic front of the
MCU they're probably stressed out about
it being a process grounded in Magic
rather than one grounded in science and
the way Thor back in Phase One described
magic as science we don't understand yet
maybe the Marvels is being pushed in a
direction as being a movie that somehow
merges the MCU understanding of Science
and the understanding of magic through
items like the Bengals the 10 rings and
other like ancient Creed Tech yeah it
sounds kind of messy I don't know how
they're going to do it maybe they don't
either but you know who might have the
answer Victor Von Doom that's who
remember Multiverse of Madness
established that dreamwalking was one
way to destabilize the Multiverse the
process of using sorcery to transport
one's Consciousness into the body of
your multiversal self Wanda was doing
this in the movie and 838 Stephen
Strange did this to defeat the a3a
Thanos at the cost of killing countless
lives in another universe and now a new
unconfirmed report from scooper the
cosmic circus is claiming unspecified
sources and it's not verified yet so
please take it with a grain of salt but
here's the claim quoting from their
report Marvel Studios will adapt
elements from the time Runs Out comic
event for Doctor Strange 3. the film
would pick up right where we left off in
Dr Strange in the Multiverse event is
where Clea traveled From Another
Dimension to seek out Doctor Strange for
his Aid in fixing the incursion that he
caused Doctor Strange has been sought
out by a multiversal organization called
the black priests Clea is a member of
this organization the black priest's HQ
will be in the nothing space of
destroyed universes which exists between
the space of two dead universes caused
by an incursion it will be revealed in
the film that the Multiverse is dying
the cause of this K as a result of the
incursions happening all across the
Multiverse the most recent being the one
caused by Doctor Strange the film will
also elaborate on a point made in the
previous movie regarding doctor strange
and his threat to the Multiverse now we
do not know how much of this is true but
here's what we do know CLIA definitely
took a three-eyed Stephen Strange into
the dark dimension in the post-credits
scene of Doctor Strange in Baltimore's
Madness
caused an incursion then we're gonna fix
it yes there is some implied we there as
in she's part of some organization we
may learn that the dark dimension is
kind of that nothing space the fact that
strange ended this movie with three eyes
and seemed totally okay with it implies
that there's some active comfortable
status quo of dreamwalking going on with
that strange in that post incursion
Universe elsewhere we also know that the
Multiverse is dying because of
incursions based on what Kang told Janet
Van Dyne in Quantum Mania but I saw how
it depends I saw their chaos
spreading across realities universes
colliding endless incursions I saw the
Multiverse and it was dying and when
Kang described this to Janet he showed
two rings two timelines with little
branches clashing into each other making
these little flashes which represent
incursions so yeah it's kind of a
no-brainer that Marvel Studios is
adapting time runs out for the lead up
to Secret Wars the close paraphrasing
from Jonathan Hickman's words or that
838 Reed Richards incursion speech made
that clear in time runs out we learned
that a group of Godlike beings called
the beyonders had set up an experiment
with a molecule man in every Universe
molecule man basically being a ticking
Time Bomb to destroy all of existence in
one boom molecule man learns what the
point of his existence is and he seeks
out the help of Doctor Doom to find all
the other molecule men and deactivate
them as molecule men get killed off the
Multiverse starts to strain as a result
and the natural mechanism to fix that
strain is incursions so the beyonders
see this happening and begin to expedite
this process a lot of groups start to
get involved and what it's called a game
of Worlds including a group called The
Black priests which are basically golden
helmeted magic elements of the
Multiverse the tltr of this is and this
time Runs Out storyline all Marvel hero
groups fight it out they all realize
that it's too late to save themselves
and we end up in battle world of Secret
Wars but yes there is a lot more to the
storyline we're gonna do a separate
video breaking it down properly don't
worry but here's the thing I know Iman
villani loves this storyline she brought
it up in our interview last year so I
think instead of molecule man the MCU is
going to use Doctor Strange which could
work given Dr Strange's big role in time
runs out but only really if in the
movies he's partnered with a Doctor Doom
that is if they were to plan for Dr Doom
to be the villain of Secret Wars and not
Kang because up until this past year it
really seemed like Kang was going to be
the main villain of the whole Multiverse
Saga that might not be the case anymore
because check this out there is another
quote from that total film article that
we found interesting from Marvel
executive Mary levanos she said in Ms
Marvel we learned that the Bengal paired
with some other form of power can force
a temporary Poland space and time and
Lead somewhere else with the power of
both Bengals more is definitely possible
and we see the culmination of that over
the course of this movie it definitely
leads to plentiful opportunities for the
future of the MCU whatever the Avengers
and Secret Wars teams may want to do
with them it kind of sounds like from
the context here she might be calling
the Avengers 5 film Avengers in The
Avengers 6 Film secret Wars why wouldn't
she call The Avengers 5 film Kang
Dynasty or Marvel Executives considering
a name change from gang Dynasty and
possibly moving away from Kang as being
the big bad of the Multiverse Saga and
more toward Doom hmm I mean I'll leave
that question with you really should
Doctor Strange be the constant of the
Multiverse Saga the cause of these
incursions or would it be more fun to
have someone else like Wanda or Loki or
Sylvie of all those characters Dr
Strange is the most recognized name to
film going audiences Doctor Strange is
the only one to have its name in the
title of a Marvel movie but more
importantly Doctor Strange has more of a
relationship with Dr Doom it would be
the battle of the doctors that idea has
me really excited and you gotta think
Stephen Strange is a medical doctor just
brings up more themes of Do no harm in
triage that might add a darker subtext
to any multiversal game of World the MCU
has planned let me know your thoughts in
the comments below subscribe to all
three of our channels of the new
rockstars Network you can follow me at
eavos thanks for watching bye
[Music]